[Musique]
pour vous présenter leur reportage qui
suit il est inutile de vous rappeler ce
qu'a été la grande guerre la première
guerre mondiale de 1914 à 1918 il faut
seulement rappeler un aspect tout à fait
particulier en effet dans le triangle
formé par les villes de bapaume d'albert
et de péronne il est tombé pendant les
grands offensive de la somme 7 tonnes de
ferraille au mètre carré
c'est tellement vrai que beaucoup de
gens gagnaient encore leur vie en
ramassant cette ferraille c'est l'objet
du reportage de louis doucet
[Applaudissements]
ou est ce que vous trouvez tout ça
monsieur
[Musique]
oui et puis un peu partout ça veut dire
être partout quand on défriche après par
exemple l'année dernière on a remis
après en pâture un grand pâture d'une
dizaine d'hectares
on en retrouve une vingtaine de 150 210
d'ailleurs on a ramassé trois cape town
vous récupérer la ferraille depuis
combien de temps ces turcs et de quatre
depuis de vue plus de 50 ans
voilà
on a chargé une connerie tiers pink a
mérité ce matin ça va dans l'autre
secteur avec succès sa sas ahmad harlez
paroisse grand succès le bambin vous
faites tout fait et pas gonds complet
encore de ferraille oui et ça qu'est ce
que c'est mais surtout ça c'est pas
vieux pierre sarraut qu'est ce que c'est
un pur st pierre s'est pas camions
américains qui provient de la guerre 14
encore oui et alors c'est au moment des
labours et vous qu'on fait là c'est la
période ont fait le travail
ouais excepté rompuy la boisson tout ça
alors yako labour que ça donne
[Applaudissements]
c'est fou ce cas là dedans carraway
pareil si c'est triste
il y avait encore tout partout je vous
en cherchez beaucoup presque tous les
jours et vous lui ni votre vie on garde
nos vies mais qu'est ce que vous faites
avec ça ils sand
ça me plaît beaucoup même oui oui
comment ça bah c'est parce que j'ai
trouvé c'est agréable et travaillent
tous partout et quel genre de trouvaille
des douilles du coup ils les cartouches
tout ce qui est tout ce qu'il ya c'est
tout ce que vous trouvez et où il ya des
morts il y avait tout ça l'air de vous
passionner s'accordent à dire oui
c'était une passion mais beaucoup de
gens dans tous ces pays cherchent encore
de la ferraille aussi ah oui oui celle
des gosses tout d'être amis cherchent du
cuivre du plomb quand ils ont à mon maïs
avant dans les champs qui ramasse un peu
de plans et ça leur plaît ils ont
ramassé beaucoup vous arrive de ravager
10 kg dans votre président vous fait
débarquer avec sa wii
bonjour en cdm aujourd'hui oui c'est des
points qu'elles sont faites exactement
comme je collectionne les tâches et
après peut-être que je leur place aussi
un petit peu sur la caisse d'epargne et
toi et toi le grand là moi j'achète des
avis et je garde un peu d'argent pour
les fêtes destination que les fabricants
d'obus n'avait certainement pas prévu
mais qui est à mon avis beaucoup plus
naturelle
[Musique]